today i am meeting with fernanda for the
first time
and today i am talking not so much just
about language learning but about
this international community
that's forming around language around
people's interests in connecting with
people from other parts of the world
and i was introduced to fernanda by
ibrahim of egypt who follows me on
twitter
and who pointed out that fernanda has a
book club and a podcast about her book
club
and she was going to be
in her book club they were going to be
discussing my book where i talk about my
experience learning languages so i
thought it would be very interesting to
chat with fernanda and before i get
going i just want to remind you that if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications uh
if you follow us on uh on spotify or
some other podcast service please leave
a review okay fernando bondiya first of
all
nice nice to meet you
steve i'm so happy to be here
i'm thankful
and
to meet you
all right thank you for having me here
no not at all i thought it was such an
interesting story
because it has to do with books with
reading with language with people
connecting so first of all
ibrahim
lives in egypt
and he suggested i
check out your
blog or podcast
and what connected you with ibrahim in
the first place can you explain the
background there yes
we are
effortless english member
and we have aj as a coach
and we have a great community great
international community
with people from all over the world
i'm brazilian
ibrahim is from egypt we have friends
from france
italy german
serbia
india
oh a lot of people and we have a great
relationship
in
this community
and i should point out for those who
don't know that aj hogg
is a tremendous uh
teacher of english he teaches by
actually helping people learn rather
than speaking things at them
so he's very much i mean i'm i i know aj
personally i've met with him and i'm a
great supporter of what he does
to bring people together around
learning english
yes
absolutely
what prompted you to start a book club
and to start a podcast about your book
club
yes
it's actually it's not a book club okay
we have a book club from our group
but i start to to do this podcast
and i combine books and languages
because i love learn languages and i
love books and books
is
books are great resource to acquire
vocabulary to have fun
learning
and have fun um
at the same time
it's so
grateful and i choose your book
because yes
as the first one
because
i love
your book this book inspired me a lot
when i first read
when i first read
your book i i just read two twice
and now i'm reading it in french
okay yes
when i first read i i
i think to myself oh my gosh i'm a
linguist because you said
everyone can be a linguist right no
yes
and
you
you you don't have uh
to be
intellectual or
a great great
uh
academic person to acquire a second
language to learn a second second late
night
i i think i think it's so
great
so great
one thing i should point out because i
always get criticism for using the word
linguist to describe someone who many
languages
in most other languages the word is
polyglot
whatever but in english if you look up
the dictionary the first meaning of
linguist is someone who speaks several
languages because after all linguistics
came along later but the word linguist
is at least 500 years old and it
describes someone who learns
and who speaks several languages and i
wrote my book
uh you know
where i can remember the name of the
book what's it called again the way of
the league the way of the language
and at that time i was unaware of the
name of the word polyglot
and
to most english speakers linguist is
someone who speaks several languages
uh it's a problem when we translate the
book because then we can't really use
the word linguist because in other
languages linguista means someone who
studies linguistics
but that i wrote that book in 2003
at that time i spoke nine languages uh
and i describe my own experience and and
yeah i encourage people to learn
languages and uh
hopefully it it
it achieves that you know anyone can do
it
but interesting so you're you have the
uh so explain your book you so you do
have a book club
ah we have a book club in our group
which is a book in effortless english or
in sao paulo
no no
just
from internet
we gather yes we gather to uh uh
all of all of us
in zone and we discussed we we discussed
every meeting we discussed one chapter
of the book
we read this book
during this the week and we discuss we
we schedule a time to discuss this
chapter of the book so let's again to be
clear so this is all in english
all in english because and these are
non-native speakers of english so these
are people who are learning english
yes yes yes and you choose a book and
then you schedule a zoom conference
and then people will come on and you
might read a portion of the book and
discuss the book and typically how many
people show up for these meetings
we had a meeting
today
in the morning
we are
seven seven
all right
yes seven
and
each one discuss one person
uh
make a little
summary of the chapter and
the others discuss the ideas
and all of these in english because
english is our common language
right
i speak portuguese
one friend french
another one i speak a
hindu
right yeah
yes indeed yes
and
and so on
do you have any native speaker there
like does aj participate or is it it's
all learners
all learners all learners great idea we
could do that with other languages too
uh yes yes absolutely i
i have a book club
in my french group
another one another one
my french group
is just with brazilian people that that
uh learn
french
and and so does this for example is is
there an organization or is there a
website or for example the french group
uh how does it get together how do you
connect with the other members
also
zone
we we use zoom
and we send a link
everyone uh
join us
join in this meeting and we discuss the
book
how do you recruit members
huh
how do you find members
ah
i get engaged in an academy
french academy in
in brazil
and
for english we get together from aj
okay
yes we we meet each other
in in twitter first
but now we have
aj has a group in gabby gabriel.com
is that g-a-b.com
yes g-a-b
all right very interesting
and but you also have a podcast because
uh ibrahim sent me a link to your
project yes yes i went and checked it
out and it was very nice like a very
nice landing page and uh
very very well done
so so can you give me a background
background on the podcast and what what
your objective is there
um
my
the reason the reason why i decided to
do this
uh
for uh it's for
my practice english
to practice in my english and improve my
english
to be able to
to speak more fluently because sometimes
i
forget the words that i want to say
and making the podcast i can
i can prepare something carefully
and
i can read the king i can speak
spontaneously also
and i think i will improve
i have friends in our group uh from
effortless enabler members that have
also
a podcast ibrahim has
a podcast a great podcast yes i should
look him up
uh you know it's very interesting so you
say you're you have the podcast in order
to improve your english
and i am sure that as you speak with me
now speaking in english which is not
your native language
that there's a certain level of anxiety
that you may not
you may miss something or you might not
be able to remember a word yet for me
listening i have the impression that
your english is totally natural
oh my gosh thank you you know it's it's
amazing the difference between how we
feel about our language where we're
worried we're going to forget then we
can't find this word we take another
word
we all do this right we can't remember
the word we want so we take some other
word and we are we change our
conversation to kind of suit the words
we're able to find and it's a certain
level of tension
but for me listening to you i don't
sense any tension whatsoever and so i
think it's an important message that we
always we're always much more nervous
than we should be
and we actually do a lot better than we
think we do
so i mean i feel the same when i speak
portuguese i make so many
yeah people understand me so it's good
enough you know
so
i'm going to leave by the way i'm going
to leave obviously links in the
description box to
to your podcast to ibrahim's podcast
i'll get that information
uh so that people can follow up
but uh i i just think
yours was such an interesting example to
me that ibrahim from egypt suggests i
talked to fernando from brazil
and you were brought together by a.j
hope from the united states and you've
got people there from serbia from france
from india from wherever
and it's a wonderful sense i mean
to be able to connect with people in any
situation i mean you want to connect
with people who live near you for
example i mean
we are happiest when we're connecting
with other people but now that we can
connect with people in in a meaningful
way it's not you know personal you can't
give a person a hug but you can connect
and so i think that's an interesting uh
example of how
the social media which often has very
negative
society can also be very positive in
bringing people together absolutely
absolutely
so where do you think your podcast will
go what do you see is as uh
you're doing it for yourself you say
your english which is already very good
you want to encourage others to do the
same thing
yes and i want to to discuss about books
sometimes i'm reading
a book and i want to discuss and i don't
have people around me to discuss and i i
i want to say
something about this book with
someone
and i think i will create this
to read to read the
great part of one book i have read
it
yeah yeah
very interesting
well um
i will uh you know i wish you the best
the best of luck i think it's a
tremendous initiative
again
my wife and i were in brazil we
thoroughly enjoyed ourselves we didn't
get to sao paulo but we got a bit of a
bit of a flavor of brazil
uh i still remember on the copacabana we
were sitting there having a beer
people
they have these in the different uh
cafes where they're they're serving beer
they also have bands and people walk by
and they're dancing the samba and
everybody yes
but
but you you go to salvador
you went
yes
el salvador is my my favorite city in
brazil yes
i'm from bahia i'm from valley
yeah
salvador was amazing
there again at night we went for a walk
and again they have bands in the
different cafes and restaurants so
you're hearing music all over the place
and we went to the old city you know
where they the slave trade you know
market was and the old portuguese style
houses and
and uh it was a it was a very
interesting city it's it's a different
flavor completely different flavor from
from rio
uh
we walked all over it took taxis uh
i mean it's got its social problems
there's massive favelas in in sao paulo
but uh we met some people actually link
members who live in in a favela
so i guess it's a life it's a life that
people get used to and that's what it is
amen
okay well thank you very much fernanda a
lot of fun and i'm sure that my viewers
will enjoy finding out about
your podcast and your book club